they're gonna make a movie about the  life of Steve Jobs the founder of Apple  and the part of Steve Jobs is gonna be  played by Christian Bale incredible  actor  yeah it's Christian Bale is gonna play  Steve Jobs believe it or not because I  don't even think they've started filming  yet believe it or not we already have a  special sneak preview what shut up in  check it out  [Music]  Wow Athens master jokes that was  frightened me  we'll put the little clicky button  hearing ho little mouse arm Steve Jobs  did you know max are easier to use with  some man no I came back to stop you  Bill Gates no one wants a tiny computer  in their phone I call it the iPhone and  our  [Applause]  [Music]  he was an intense guy all right  you